as president vladimir putin ordered
russian troops into eastern ukraine
western sanctions were issued in
response today the uk is sanctioning the
following five russian banks
rossia is bank gen general bank
a promising as bank and the black sea
bank and we are sanctioning three very
high net worth individuals gennady
timchenko boris rottenberg and igor
rotenberg the british prime minister
called it a first barrage promising more
if putin advances deeper into ukraine eu
sanctions were also restrained targeting
members of parliament and limiting
russian access to european capital
markets and washington has banned u.s
business dealings with the two breakaway
regions in eastern ukraine germany did
go further calling a halt to the 11
billion dollar nordstream 2 pipeline
project highly prized by russia and
built to deliver gas to europe bypassing
ukraine but russian investment experts
say none of it will trouble the kremlin
the the banks that have been mentioned
are
are all state banks that are funded
domestically uh don't not rely on the
european markets have not for years
because they have been
subject to
u.s sanctions and the individuals that
we mentioned
uh are certainly uh
part of kind of putin's uh circular
friends but they have also been subject
to u.s sanctions
uh for many years so so really what the
uk and you eu are doing now is simply
catching up with sanctions that have
been in place by the u.s for many years
the threat of full sanctions retaliation
is being held in reserve depending what
putin does next measures dubbed
sanctions from hell by the u.s senate
would in theory target whole sectors and
industries with crippling economic
effect it is a threat that one prominent
kremlin critic believes lacks
credibility he um invaded georgia no
sanctions from hell he took crimea no
sanctions from hell he shot down a
passenger plane with uh with 298
innocent people no sanctions from hell
and all of a sudden we're threatening
sanctions from hell and what do we do we
make a a minor tepid addition to the u.s
sanctions list
basically coming up to where they were
four years ago that's not credible that
doesn't scare putin he doesn't believe
we're for real
part of the problem is western resolve
stiff sanctions against russia would
hurt europe in return with strong ties
in trade and energy another is russian
resilience holding the world's fifth
largest financial reserves built up
especially to cushion the blow
ultimately the calculation is putin's
alone to make he's got away with it so
far he may feel there's insufficient
reason to turn back now
joe nahul al jazeera